ah these no no banana great hey guys we
are here with Fandango I'm Tom I'm Jacob
and we are gonna be interviewing each
other oh I'm gonna kick it off in there
how has the snack affected MJ and how
does she evolve as a character in this
film it kind of puts our characters in a
special place cuz now we're like I don't
know we come back in the worlds kind of
changed and we all kind of have to
depend on each other a little bit more
because we're like the oddballs of
children we kind of have to confine each
other with that experience that's cool
and then I know I know I think in the
first movie obviously you didn't really
get to see much of her but she was like
a very guarded sarcastic character and I
think I kind of get to see why she has
that guard and slowly watch her mouth a
little bit
I think MJ like wouldn't even be faced
by the snap she's like go and come back
in me like oh cool
anyway to book everywhere I go I see his
face just really miss him I miss him too
[Music]
I don't think Tony would have done what
he did if he didn't know that you were
gonna be here after he was gone when the
spider-mans broke now look like with
Harmon I mean it's very emotional saying
about him and what was quite scary for
me is this is obviously the first
spider-man film I've made without Robert
so yeah so it was a bit daunting but
that's why it's nice to have checked in
on we'll come in and play Mysterio in
this film because he kind of fills the
shoes of Peters mentor yeah and he does
it really nicely which is great
what's the best way to support a
superhero friend basically you tell him
he's the best and telling you guys back
and if there's any problem call me
what's the most annoying thing about
reappearing five years later after the
snap Brad Davis he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's after my girl
good what do you think would be the most
you would have missed five seasons of
love Island that would be really bad but
also that means you have five extra
years on your life you know I love let
me jump five years in the future but the
phones that we have in the film upgrade
the phone
the phones and they've been doing so
much cleanup and you know like dealing
with that yeah yeah that's one no one
had his hands in the Olark don't what is
that look easy weather is well performs
yeah in the future they released a car
or something
remember all and then they all happen to
be Sony phones and then Sony tech nice
nice you're all right I don't know I
don't want to you don't want to go
spirit please
I was on a different planet when the
snap happened well you guys pretty sure
I'm at your house already yeah with me
okay what we doing man names hanging up
I was assumed you're gonna come back
from space and we could build another
lego Duff's
that didn't happen yeah I I guess I feel
like you'd be reading and then you
notice your hand going and you'd like
try and get as much reading isn't my
drip with the girl who I really like and
tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not
I mean it's kind of obvious Tom what was
the hardest scene to shoot with me all
do scenes of working with you is tough
difficult the scene before we go on our
date on the bridge yeah yeah it's tough
because we have to do the scene and then
we'd have to stop and let like and hide
in that 10 yeah I'd hit 10 and let
traffic go through and then we usually
come back out and then it got really
late and there's nothing I like you hear
a good kid there's a part of me that
wants me to tell you just turn around
run away from all this and then there's
another part of me that knows what we're
about to fight what's at stake I'm glad
you're here
Mysterio is a major character in this
movie was the most mysterious thing
about yourself so many people don't know
about me is I'm actually fluent in
Portuguese
[Music]
no I'm getting it Idris is just
something that some people don't know
about you so we can we can upload truth
accession Jacob and I were recently in
LA and he came to my hotel and had a few
few drinks at the bar so then he
couldn't stay he could obviously drive
home because we don't do drink driving
no obviously so he stayed at Meijer in
my hotel room and he slept in the living
room and and I woke up to this like
strobe light going off and it's like
super loud alarm and then all of a
sudden this lady came over the town she
was like fire fire evacuate the building
fire fire fire alarms going on this is
mr. bet you couldn't use someone like
you on my world new world Beck is from
Earth just not house a snap to our home
in our dimension we have a job to do
you're coming with us if you met someone
who knew nothing about spider-man all
the movies what would you tell them is
going on in this one I think if you've
got this far in life without watching a
Marvel movie they're not for you yeah
doesn't count as a fake ID if your
birthday is correct and five years have
passed but you're still in range well
that's why all my classmate when you see
the closer than my past well there's no
date
[Music]
I loved it like the most serious event
in the entire MCU is called the blip
it's not a blip it's a it's like a it's
like a mass genocide
it's gonna be great
I'm just gonna enjoy my trip hang out
with MJ good really pretty and therefore
I have value no no that's not what I
meant
I'm messing with you Elias spider-man
far from home hit states is July 2nd
stop putting my friends in danger the
world needs next Iron Man
you're going to step up or not
[Music]
[Music]